well aside from the beautiful music and
the storyline you shot the film right
here the Senate on did and it's just
excellent do you think a lot of people
realize that you're the cinematographer
I did it seems like that part doesn't
get mentioned as much thank you and that
means a lot and I i set out actually i
had to draw to dps that I really wanted
her work with jason warner might work
with the foreign air in moorhead both of
them were just schedule conflicts they
couldn't do it Jason had just had a baby
he couldn't come out for you know about
a month to shoot and I hit up actually a
few filmmakers out of la that I i really
enjoy their work but we didn't have that
much money to really afford to fly them
out and have them shoot for a month so I
just said you know i'm gonna i'm going
to give it a shot because i was on the
set watching those two masters aaron and
jason do their thing and i felt i could
at least make it look decent you know
any because the money I just didn't feel
it would be someone in a new
relationship type of situation where I
could say hey I don't know you at all
which would you come out and shoot for a
month on you know a very low budget with
no money and you know crew of three
people most dps i would say what's
especially if they don't know me for not
my friend they would be a little worried
about that you know cuz that's the
situation usually friends would do like
yeah man i'll do it with you but that's
why I kind of had to shoot it on my own
that was the choice so but I'm actually
yeah I'm happy with the half the shots
but yeah I mean I know everyone could
the dp's I know could have done better
but at least I'm happy with you know
most people don't know when they're
watching it that like oh everything was
great except it look terrible like thank
God that doesn't happen
do you think that the parts where you
might cringe other people would have no
no inkling that there was anything wrong
if so many artists are so critical that
other people even notice something that
the artists themselves would write think
it's a glaring right right i think it's
i think it's half and half i'm sure you
know a technical DP watching it would
cringe with me but i think the general
moviegoers people who just go just to
sit back and take in the film i don't
think it would notice too much they
probably just think oh it's it's
supposed to look like that well now are
you slated to do two new projects i
thought from looking at your IMDB use i
am i'm i'm developing there's there's
two on IMDb that were kind of almost
ready to go and then of course with
financing they kind of always fall apart
and even you know the hollywood level or
the independent DIY level is always like
a project that's just about to get going
and then something falls apart so those
are still on the back burner I'm
actively like working on the scripts
trying to attach different talent here
and there so it's something that I'm
excited about but right now as of today
I'm really working towards doing another
film that's not even listed and I don't
wanna release able to talk about because
you know it probably if it falls apart
then it's another thing that's public
that fell apart so this one I'm trying
to shoot by the summer and it's
something that if it if it's done right
it'll be something where I really want
to take it to you know Sherman song got
me so much exposure but I definitely
want you know always trying to do better
and bigger for the next thing
and do you plan to actually shoot any of
the three that you mentioned or will it
be another happy accident where if
someone falls out funding is right i
think i would shooter only if i had to i
was i was on a high with you knowing
Soderberg shoots his own films and you
know directly and I was like yeah you
know what he's my inspiration I can do
it and then the funniest stories were on
the set with kristina Rose particularly
there was a day where is she had this
great take and I screwed up the shot you
know the actual shot so I said cut and
the first thing after I said cut was
and she's like oh my god you know
like she thought it was her I was like
no no no sorry like i should say I
separating myself from DP and director
was a little hard to be able to you know
like I should have said cut gave her
some feedback and then maybe kept my own
cameraman feedback to myself the other
thing i think i said if i were to DP i
would have a camera operator I think
that was the main thing I camera
operated and directed it it's just a
little overwhelming so I think next time
if I worst-case had to DP myself I would
at least hire a camera operator
you